hi I'm RIA I'm a tasty producer and
today I'm going to show you how to cook
Japanese for entire day Japanese
traditional breakfast consists of rice
miso soup grilled fish and some side of
the sheets like tamagoyaki egg omelette
it's my favorite if I have to choose a
last meal I'll definitely choose
Japanese breakfast commonly we use a
rectangle pan this pan is just made to
make tamagoyaki you'll pour egg mixture
very thin almost like making a crepe
then you roll them up and repeat the
process until you run out of egg mixture
it looks very technical and difficult
that it's not that difficult I think
when I made it for the first time I was
12 years old in this video we used
cheese and nori seaweed but you can make
it plain it's a staple dish for
breakfast or bento
another typical main dish for Japanese
breakfast it's grilled fish like salmon
maybe it seems odd for people from other
culture but this is what I grown up
eating with I think Japanese people eat
a lot of fish because our country is
surrounded by ocean myself I grown up in
a small fisherman town eating with a lot
of fish breakfast lunch and dinner
it's one of my comfort food it's a full
of healthy fats and vitiates a very
important part of Japanese diet another
staple dish for Japanese breakfast is
Mississippi tofu it's one of the common
ingredient I will demonstrate how
Japanese chef cut tofu on your part my
mom told me how to do it correctly so
first pick up the tofu put on your palm
tofu it's very soft and fragile slice
horizontally and then cut very gently as
long as you are not pulling or pushing
the knife on your palm it's safe to cut
but if you are beginner cook wait until
you are comfortable hunter in your knife
I don't want young audience to watch
this video and go enjoy themselves
basic ingredients for Mississippi its
wakame seaweed tofu and enoki mushrooms
but you can use any kind of vegetables I
think each family or region have their
own way of making miso soup my mom
always prepared breakfast for us I
didn't realize how time-consuming it was
to prepare breakfast in traditional way
I began to appreciate more than 1/4 it
took since I started living by myself in
the u.s. now my typical breakfast is
coffee and maybe some yoga but I still
miss both the taste and nutritious value
of a classic Japanese breakfast for
lunch some months makes bento called
caliban which eats shorten words for
character bento which is a trend in
Japan caliban is a decorated bento which
features food decorated look like
animals or characters my mom used to
make me rabbit shaped boiled egg or
octopus shaped winner for my bento
I remember made me smile whenever I see
those kawaii animals in my bento box my
mom who made me bento everyday when I
was in high school my favorite bento
ingredients was fried chicken also she
often put left over from dinner or
breakfast for example tamagoyaki from
breakfast or fried chicken from dinner
we bring Bentall to office we bring
bento school we can also buy bento at
the station and you can eat it in a
train onigiri eats typical item for
bento onigiri is basically a rice ball
basic rice ball it's seasoned with salt
has the Maebashi inside and rubbed with
a piece of nori seaweed I remember my
brother made banana fritter onigiri for
Mother's Day when she was little it was
pretty bad but I think my mom didn't
want to hurt his feelings so she was
eating them
again I took for granted my mom making
all those great amazing food for me
thank you mom okonomiyaki it's my soul
food the best way of describing
okonomiyaki is savory pancake there are
two types of okonomiyaki the Osaka style
and hiroshima style I'm from Hiroshima
so that's the star I grew
wait whenever someone visit my hometown
everyone always will tell them to go out
to economy aki with their friends and
family all the ingredients are layered
and contains noodles since it's
basically made of its flour egg and
cabbage it's a budget dinner you can
make it a home the sauce is called
okonomiyaki sauce it's a little sweet
almost like barbecue sauce you can find
them easily in Asian grocery store in
the US I love that my hometown had such
amazing recipe to represent it I also
make it all the time at home for my
friends and family my husband eats pixon
and he really loved this dish I remember
my non-japanese friend sit down because
when you top bonito flakes on top of
something really ha it moves almost
looks like dancing economy Rocky's
ingredient it's really accessible I can
make it wherever I go and bring a part
of Hiroshima with me I've already talked
about mesmerizing Japanese that are in
last video so I don't introduce a quick
dessert you can make in a rice cooker
most people use rice cooker for just
cooking rice but you can cook so many
other things in it once you get to know
your rice cooker it's your friend this
is a much easier way of making a Giri
cheese game which I know many of you
seems to like a lot it may sounds
difficult to cook authentic Japanese
food outside of Japan but I think it's
not too hard the recipe I introduced
today it's using accessible ingredients
all throughout the world it's the
easiest way to make you feel like you
are traveling to Japan I talked about in
my last video how cooking Japanese food
was an easy way for me to feel at home
whenever I started feeling homesick but
now I've been in the US for 10 years but
still my favorite food is Japanese food
I've come to love my new home but when I
can bring elements of Japan into the US
and introduce it to other people
reminds me of where I came from and that
Japan will always be my true home I love
showing people Japanese recipes because
they see a bit of my home and seeing
their maids reaction makes me happy
why is your favorite Japanese dish
Oh oh yes was i smiling
[Music]